well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
former scottish labour leader now
director
of the john smith center kezia dugdale
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace great to see you both
more from you just a moment as ever
let's start with the front pages
the guardian reports that fewer than
half of recent labor voters
in hartlepool say they'll back the party
in thursday's by-election
leading activists to fear a historic
conservative victory
the telegraph leading with the collapse
of the murder trial of two former
soldiers
accused of murdering the ira commander
joe mccann in 1972
that's also the lead story for the daily
mail their headline
now end witch hunts for good
the metro goes with the trial for the
murder of former footballer dalian
atkinson
who it's alleged was tasered for 33
seconds
leading up to his death according to the
financial times the uk mortgage market
is now worth nearly 12 billion pounds
as people aim to snap up properties
before the end of the stamp duty holiday
in june
and an explosion at a house in kent is
on the front page of the mirror
which says a 99 year old grandmother was
saved by
two hero passers-by so kezie and mark
are here with their choices
not surprisingly perhaps kicking off
with the guardian
labor alarm as party data points to a a
collapse in support
um kez do you want to kick off with this
um given your previous role in politics
uh what is happening do you think is
this still brexit hangover
i think it may well be yes certainly in
the north of england so today it didn't
start particularly well for keir starmer
with a poll coming out showing the
tories well ahead in hartley pool
that's remarkable because the tories
have never won that seat in the history
of the constituency
existing so to take the seat and with
boris johnson's current poll ratings and
the wider picture across the uk would be
a real achievement
the guardian tomorrow shows more
headaches for keir starmer with internal
labour contact information the actual
door-to-door canvassing work that
they've been doing
showing that they're going to have a
real problem turning out enough of a
vote on poland
to win the seat so problems are mounting
up for keir starmer but at the same time
you know he's got to make a long road
back from
where he is to power based on what he's
inherited from the previous labour
leadership so
the question really that should be posed
is whether there's unreasonable
expectations of the amount of progress
that kirsten should be making by this
stage in the campaign
and how much of this is down to boris
johnson then mark um i know
sebastian payne up in the northeast um
suggested people were saying about
wallpapergate
oh he deserves nice wallpaper after what
he'd been through with covid so
who knows how much that is cutting
through but but what is it about the
popularity or otherwise of boris johnson
well i think you've got to see this as
part of a much much longer story than
boris even than jeremy corbyn or brexit
you think all the way back to
2004 the regional assembly referendum in
the northeast
the only big electoral defeat that tony
blair ever suffered
was dealt by people in the northeast
deciding to vote
against the labour party it was an
opportunity i think that people took
because it was
an opportunity to give labour a bit of a
shoeing without at that time seeming to
endorse the tories
this end of the love affair of a lot of
people
not all but a lot of people in labour's
former heartlands has been growing for a
very long time
and the reason brexit and boris matter
is that
that the former provided a window of
opportunity and the latter seized the
opportunity
to actually convert that from people
being disillusioned with labor
to testing out an alternative so if it's
the case that
two years you know a year and a half on
from the general election new
labour seats are potentially falling to
this government
beyond what they suffered in 2019 that
that itself is quite a remarkable
achievement
so mark is is is an oversimplification
to say that
if the ukip vote disappears it's got to
go somewhere
and and this is where it's going is it
is it that simple is this a transference
of vote
well i think what part of what's
happened is ukip and then the brexit
party to a certain extent acted as a
kind of
gateway drug as it were to for people
there was a way for people to
leave labour to stop thinking about
themselves necessarily as being
as you know say left-wing as they were
being told they were
and actually you know quite a lot of
voters have been in to some extent
laundered through
having somewhere else to go first so
quite a lot of people who voted brexit
party are undoubtedly
switching tori now or have switched all
in the last couple of years
but it's much more complicated than just
our world people went one way now they
go another
actually abandoning a lifelong voting
habit
is really really hard testing out a new
one
if anything is even harder so these are
very difficult processes for each
individual voter to go through and i
don't think we can
kind of minimize it yes absolutely and
all lies obviously
um well if we've got daily telegraph on
secure stamina
um he's suggesting he needs a bit more
time um he wouldn't he never promised to
do this in a year but
is there recognition for him will it
come what does he need to do do you
think to
to get out of that sort of north london
bubble and and make waves
kezia that's to you apologies sorry
so i think first of all we shouldn't
draw trends from by-elections they're
notoriously difficult
things to measure to poll and need to
draw any serious conclusions from
the worrying thing in this guardian
article is that there is a threat to
labour stronghold in local authority
areas in northeast
places like sunderland that's perhaps
more worrying
for heads in labor hq tonight but i
think keir starmer
is very fair and reasonable to expect
more time to to build up his name
to build up his platform manifesto that
he wants to put forward
really the only thing he's been able to
talk about over the past 12 months is
the handling of the coverage crisis
and we're in an odd position now that
after arguably months and months of
mishandling the covered crisis
the government now have a good news
story in the form of the vaccine so
that's why you see a thicker starmer
sort of deferring to this argument of a
sort of vaccine bounce for the
government that
he just can't contend with i think
kirsten would much rather be
debating and arguing in these elections
on a domestic policy agenda rooted in
education and justice and investment in
housing
instead he's doing the backdrop of a
pandemic where the vaccines are the
major story of the moment
and there's lots of money going into
supporting furlough scheme and holding
up the economy
how long that can last is a separate
question but it's certainly going to
last past thursday's local election
well it's going to be a fascinating few
days isn't it the uh the hartley pool
result overnight on thursday
mark i know you'll be joining our
coverage and then more results crucially
also because you're from scotland too
friday saturday uh council elections all
weekend
lots to look forward to anyway if you're
a fan of elections uh mark let's move on
shall we
a story in a number of the newspapers
not surprisingly the
metro their headline no evidence judge
clears
x paras over the 1972 murder
of an ira leader the daily mail now
and witch hunts for good they've long
been campaigning
against uh bringing veterans to court
your assessment of what we saw today in
this case
well this is going to be far from the
end of what we hear what we hear about
this row you remember that tensions
about this case and these types of cases
contributed to
johnny mercer the the well-known
prominent ex-army
uh mp resigning from from his role in
the government he's been out in
belfast expressing his support for the
veterans who've been facing this trial
and i think there's a number of
different layers to it the first one
is exactly what we've seen with this
decision so the idea of
the question of competence frankly on
the part of prosecutors you know we have
this stark fact that the judge has ruled
ineligible the statements that the
soldiers themselves had to give
and were ordered to give without legal
representation by their superiors
immediately after the
the shooting um that's something that
prosecutors then
didn't try to appeal or push back on and
that's what's caused ultimately this
case to collapse
you've got to say dragging a case like
this so
tense with so many uh with people's
lives on the line but
but also with so much attention on it
dragging it through court
on what seems to be such a flimsy basis
is very troubling
then then there's the wider issue of is
it really possible to
for a government or any parliament to
decide to prevent
any future prosecutions like this
frankly i don't think it is for the good
reason that you can't retrospectively
say you know what
even if coins had been committed we will
change the law so they won't they won't
be punished you know but that would
clearly be the wrong thing to do
yeah i mean there's big questions here
aren't there kezier what do you do about
the victims of the troubles on both
sides
and how does that help reconciliation
which is clearly
presumably what northern ireland
ultimately has to move to
yes and there was the promise of the
truth and reconciliation commission
that's never really come to the fore
and this is obviously extremely
difficult we're talking about trying to
prosecute
people for something which happened 50
years ago that in and of itself
feels unjust but at the same time there
have been
i think 26 different attempts at
prosecution since 2011 and when you look
at the detail of those
21 of them are loyalists in republican
paramilitaries there's
a very few incidences so far of service
personnel being pursued
yet if you look at the papers today you
would think that was perhaps the only
thing that was being
addressed in the recent history of
northern ireland and of course this all
comes at a very difficult very
tempestuous time northern ireland
politics that has ramifications for
peace in northern ireland and it has
wider ramifications for the united
kingdom as a whole as an
entity so very sensitive very difficult
topic and it is going to run for weeks
yet
just a quick word mark if you don't mind
on another story which is the
the ongoing issue about covet passports
uh nhs app the telegraph suggesting may
not
be ready in time um yes should we be
surprised at that so
paper passports might be necessary
yet more problems with with grand i.t
schemes was quite frustrating kezie was
talking rightly earlier about the great
success of the vaccine program
what we've got to then make sure we can
do is actually capitalize on it and
surely being able to prove
you've been vaccinated to be able to go
to a country that says you've got to be
able to prove vaccination to get in
is one of those benefits so if we're
unable to capitalize that on that
you know frustrations will grow among
people yeah presumably they're working
on it and we'll get the uh
the list of countries eventually this
week won't we or some of them to start
off with anyway
uh plenty from you uh both in just a
moment coming up then what's behind the
apparent boom in the uk
mortgage market discussing that in just
a moment
in april 2017 my mum was diagnosed with
motor neurone disease which is
just an absolutely devastating condition
where the muscles all slowly shut down
so for her it started off with her arm
and then
from there she was even unable to turn
over in bed unable to walk
unable to speak taste or drink for her
mouth and it was
it was just heartbreaking to see someone
you loved so much
suffer so greatly um and then just
sort of add more fuel on the fire later
that year
my dad giles was diagnosed with a glioba
stomach tumor
tumor essentially a great bore brain
tumor the most serious now
i suppose a year's death sentence so
in that year yeah it took a lot of
adapting for me and my sister and it was
incredibly shocking at such a young age
because everything was
absolutely fine until then suddenly
everything just
went wrong cycling's really helped me
during lockdown
and i of course i took the year out to
sort of catch my breath
and potentially do a bit of travelling
and i certainly caught my breath but
the travelling bit's been a bit more
complicated so
um i suppose i just want to see britain
at the same time and
uh i want to do it for some purpose so
raising money for two charities that are
really close to my heart is
something that i love the sound of and
of course it's going to be
tough and i'm at the moment i'm actually
speaking to you from reading i'm doing a
training expedition up to oxford to
visit some friends so
sort of at the last date last leg of it
and it's been it's been tough but it's
been really good just
being on the bike and going from a to b
every day to keep me entertained for
seven weeks essentially i'm gonna
be trialing a lot of breakfasts and
trying to find the best one
this nation has to offer so we'll be
starting off
along the south coast then heading up
north towards bristol
and then around the whole welsh coast
and from there um i'm not entirely sure
where i'll go but i want to get up to
scotland
of course to try and finish off britain
but
we'll we'll play it by year as to where
i go from wales
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now kezia doug
dale and mark wallace welcome back to
both of you
kezia let's go to the ft shall we uh the
criticism from some
that this stamp duty relief is
unnaturally driving the housing market
but um
certainly seems people are keen on it
yes we're having a housing boom a
friendly of people borrowing to buy
houses not least because they want to do
so before the stamp duty
uh relief tax relief comes into effect
so at the moment you can buy a house in
england and wales not in scotland
for less than five hundred thousand
pounds and not pay any tax on it that
will be the case until june
and then it'll taper off until september
where you can pay no tax in the first
quarter of a million pounds
so it's leading to record levels of
borrowing and to me it speaks to a tale
of two different types of economic
uh covert experience for those who are
able to save and pay off their credit
card debts
they've got the aspirations to buy the
bigger house the rest of the country is
dealing with
precarious employment wondering if
they've got a job to go back to when
furlough ends
picture of two britons really yeah
absolutely and the question remains or
lingers about how to pay for it all
uh mark what has rishi sunak been saying
well this is an interesting hint from
the chancellor that he might be able to
avoid
some of the more painful tax risers that
have been floated
particularly if the economy grows faster
than expected in the last couple of
weeks we've seen some really encouraging
forecasts from international bodies from
uh banks
and other economic models that the uk is
said to have quite a big economic boom
if that happens that could help to fill
a lot of the gap that the chancellor
has in his calculations and avoid having
to come
uh with his swag bag to raid taxpayers
coffers for it
a quick final look uh in our final story
kezia daily mail front page which is
that
meghan markle has written a book due to
be published in june
um about a dad and his child mark you're
laughing already the daily mail
not so keen about this one but anyway
tell us tell us about it
yes imagine by surprise the daily mail
are not keen on meghan markle writing a
children's book
you know if there was a textbook about
what she was going to do in her life
beyond the royal family i think this
would be on page three of it there's a
little bit of the predictability to it
but
it's a great story there's going to be a
market for this book it's going to sell
you can't really blame her for doing it
and i'm sure somewhere there'll be a lot
of money
going to charity as a consequence that's
a good point actually isn't it mark just
10 seconds
it's another chance not not to hear
about meghan markle and
definitely not to market themselves in a
privacy loving way yeah absolutely
privacy loving is always the way the
daily mail describes her
mart wallace kezie dugdale lovely to see
you both we'll see you at half 11 for
more thank you